[Music]
god of thunder king khan you have
finally joined our fight well they say
better late than not at all
this is very nice
as you know we used to live in a
peaceful of us
but in our gods were murdered murdered
and now our sacred temple has been left
unguarded and hope was dissolved to
control of its power it is our most
sacred shrine and it desecrates not for
tell them what happened here today so at
the time that thor
the drag tag motley crew misfit
desperados turned the tide in the battle
and x their names in history the odds
may be against us but i'll tell you this
for free here we go this
and
here and now
there's the maniac who seeks to end us
all
i'm putting together the greatest team
ever are you packed
[Music]
yes
[Music]
valkyrie this is the best day of my life
[Music]
they also scream quite a lot
you said this would be a relaxing
holiday
i said it was going to be like a
relaxing holiday
human handshake
it's the asgardian shake
into the snake
that you cannot trust
really dragging this out and finish the
classic asgardian high one
it deals july 8 tickets on sale now
[Music]
you